[Musique]
ça fait du bien tous ces arbres on est
obligé de sortir la tête haute et de
lever les yeux au ciel il ya des chênes
et hêtres et frame quelques érables et
surtout beaucoup de châtaignier dans
cette forêt aïe ça pique pas les
châtaignes
c'est un peu trop tôt les orties
elles portent bien leur nom un sache aux
orties urtica en latin vient de l'euro
qui signifie brûlé comment des feuilles
peuvent-elles provoquer une telle
réaction ça donne vraiment envie de
gratter mais pas trop quand même
tout se passe en surface les feuilles
des orties sont recouvertes de poils
urticants allez on va les voir ça de
plus près et la petite caméra à
photographier de très très près une
horde y regarder on voit très bien les
poils qui se dressent à la surface de la
feuille
comme vous pouvez le consulter ce ne
sont pas vraiment des poils mais des
petits réservoirs ils ressemblent à des
gens pour vous savez celles qui
contiennent un médicament et libèrent
leurs contenus de la même manière
lapointe et en silice le matériau de
base avec lequel on fait du verre c'est
elle qui s'enfonce dans nos tissus comme
elle est très fragile elle se brise
instantanément comme l'extrémité une
ampoule et des verts se sont contenues
dans nos tissus et la simple qu'est ce
qu'il y à là dedans
[Musique]
je vous préviens je le fait qu'une fois
de l'histamine responsables de
l'inflammation et des démangeaisons de
l'acide formique le poison produit par
les fourmis et les abeilles de la
sérotonine également responsable de
l'inflammation et de l'acétylcholine une
substance impliqué dans les chocs
allergiques
mais pas de panique l'ortt il en produit
qu'en toute petite quantité juste
histoire de marquer les esprits de nos
éloigné d'elle et de repousser les
herbivores
pas de quoi s'alarmer donc et piétiné
toutes les orties que nous rencontrons
sur notre passage d'autant que cette
plante peut être très utile
on peut en faire un engrais un pesticide
naturel
on peut aussi l'a consommée sous forme
de soupes
si si bon là il va me manquer un peu je
retourne en fait lire en forêt je vais
très bien ici
au passage je vous invite à porter des
gants cas il y avait également des poils
urticants au niveau de la tige allez
c'est parti
[Musique]
alors je sais ce n'est pas très
appétissant
et pourtant on peut aussi consommer les
feuilles d'ortie quand elles sont
fraîches
pour cela il faut choisir une feuille
tout jeune comme celle ci et ça peut
même se faire à mains nues l'idée c'est
d'attraper la feuille par le dessous car
sur les jeunes pousses il y a moins de
poils urticants dessous que dessus dans
la dh
puis on l'a replie sur elle-même on
écrase bien pour briser toutes les
petites ampoules et les vider de leur
liquide ont rempli la feuille sur elle
même
et on passe une fois supplémentaire en
appuyant bien y compris aux extrémités
voilà et maintenant on peut déguster
fanny pic absolument pas allez je m'y
remets
[Musique]
là je dois avoir pas loin d'un
kilogramme
[Musique]
pour 4 personnes il faut compter 700
grammes d'or vous commencez par les
laisser au soleil ou à l'air libre
histoire que les poils urticants se
dessèchent pour que les feuilles ne
présente plus aucun enjeu
passé ce délai est bien vous voyez vous
pouvez saisir les tiges et détachez les
feuilles
ça nous piquent plus du tout vous l'avez
les feuilles à l'eau claire
puis vous faites fondre une noix de
beurre dans une casserole vous pouvez
éventuellement rajouter un onu vous y
déposez les feuilles d'ortie et vous les
faites suer pour leur fait perdre un
maximum d'humidité
puis vous ajoutez un litre d'eau si vous
laissez mijoter au bout d'un quart
d'heure une demi heure quand les
feuilles commencent à se déliter
économique soeur de la crème fraîche et
c'est prêt vous avez quoi et je veux en
faire pousser un peu dans mon jardin
pour pas que pour la cuisine
une vingtaine d'espèces de papillons
peau exclusivement sur les orties et en
plus elle héberge certains parasites les
pucerons notamment qui préfèrent aussi
installer plutôt que sur mes premiers
gouttes
[Musique]
c'est pas mauvais mais j'ajoute un
poivre ce manque de piquant aller à très
bientôt pour une nouvelle capsule des
conflits nés longo vous pouvez retrouver
la recette de la soupe aux orties à la
page 83 de mon livre tu l'as dit jamie
illustré par leslie plée aux éditions
stock